the price of a visit to the dentist is
fifty dollars if the dentist fills any
cavities an additional charge of one
hundred dollars per cavity gets added to
the bill
if the dentist finds n cavities what
will the cost of the visit b
write your answer as an expression all
right so we're talking about the cost of
the visit so you're gonna spend fifty
dollars no matter what
and then you're gonna get and then
you're gonna get an additional charge of
one hundred dollars per capita they tell
us an additional charge of one hundred
dollars per cavity so let's see if you
have n cavities it's going to be a
hundred dollars times n hundred i could
just write this as a hundred and let's
see if this makes sense if you have no
cavities if n is zero then you're just
gonna pay your fifty dollars but if you
have one cavity you're gonna pay your
fifty dollars plus a hundred times one
if you have two cavities you're gonna
pay fifty dollars plus a hundred times
two yeah this seems to make sense so
let's check our answer we got it right
let's do another one of these sunny
earns 12 dollars per hour delivering
cakes she worked for x hours this week
she worked for x hours this week
unfortunately she was charged 15 for a
late delivery on tuesday how much money
did sunny earn this week
so if you see that she she earns 12
dollars per hour and she worked for x
hours say okay she got 12 dollars per
hour times x hours so that's how much
she would have made except for the fact
that she also had she was charged i
guess her employer charges her for late
delivery so she had to take 15
out of her paycheck so this is what she
would have gotten paid based on her
hourly wage and the number of hours she
worked but then she has that late fee
that she has to pay so it's going to be
12x minus 15 is how much she actually
earned this week
let's do let's do a few more of these
there are c players on the cougar on the
cougars hockey team the team scored a
total of 36 goals this season
one of the players matthew scored two
more goals than the average per player
how many goals did matthew score
all right well let's think about the
average per player because we know he
scored two more than the average per
player so the average is going to be the
total number of goals
divided by the number of players and
they tell us they're c players so this
this expression right over here that
will tell us the average that that's the
that's the average goals per player now
we know matthew scored two more than
this thing over here so we can just add
two to that and that's how many goals
matthew scores
let's check our answer and the key here
this might seem a little confusing but
remember it says matthew scored two more
goals
two more goals than the average player
the average player the average goals per
player is 36 divided by c
let's do
let's do one more of these
hannah has 127 books in her collection
her school is hosting a book donation
there are z students at her school and
they each plan to donate the same amount
of books and reach a total donation of
300 books
how many books will will hannah have in
her collection after her donation
all right so let's let's think about
hannah has 127 books in her collection
that's how much she has in her
collection her school is hosting a book
donation there are z students at her
school and they each plan to donate the
same amount of books and reach a total
of 300 books
how many books will hannah have in her
collection after her donation so 127 and
i don't just reread it because at first
i was like okay wait is 127 the amount
of books that hannah has or the amount
that her school has we'd be very clear
127 is the number of books hannah has
then she's going to donate some of those
books so she's going to donate some of
those books to her school and we have to
figure out how much is she going to
donate to her school and we see that the
students the z students plan on together
and they each want to donate the same
number of books and together they're
going to donate 300 books so e how much
is each student going to donate
well if they're if they're if z students
together are donating 300 each student
is going to donate 300 divided by z
divided by z
and so hannah starts with 127 books
she's going to donate her share of books
to the school
and each student is going to donate 300
divided by z books so hannah is going to
be left with 127 minus 300 over z books
after her donation